[Music]  Cybertron is in ruins was lost  Optimus at this moment we must focus on  surviving as a race not winning a war  yet again the Autobots have escalated  this conflict to the point where we must  answer their aggression with force I  have powers Decepticons to bring this  painful chapter of our history BC  extinction at the hands of the  Decepticons Cybertron strength  IVA tried and needs freedom we must not  allow Megatron to find the Allspark with  it he will destroy everything you are  you're fighting to win and that's gonna  get you all champ  the Autobots fight for the day love to  have to fight this is not the life I  imagined first it's a life worth  fighting for  [Music]  [Music]